for joining us tonight at five o'clock
i'm sasha loftis
we start with a developing traffic
situation traffic situation rather in
the northwest valley
after a man has unfortunately taken his
own life this happened on the 215
northern beltway near hualapai where the
freeway just opened back up
madison kimbrough joins us live near the
scene with the latest developments here
madison yes sasha we're right near the
hualapai off ramp and as you can see
cars are able to enter the westbound 215
freeway
this way but we were just told seconds
ago that the westbound lanes on the 215
are now open
to drive through under the overpass now
earlier reports came in that a man
jumped from the hualapai overpass on to
the 2 15
around 2 this afternoon the man who has
not been identified was pronounced dead
on scene
traffic was backed up for a good while
as nhp arrived on scene and blocked the
road
it's unclear how they were alerted to
the incident as no officers were present
at the time
but we do know that no vehicles were
struck when the man
jumped currently nhp and csi are still
on scene
now as for other road closures the
northbound lane from the hualapai
overpass
towards deer springs is still closed so
drivers are having to get on the 215
headed eastbound and then redirect
westbound and get off here
at the hualapai exit now something that
i want you guys to look at and take a
closer look
is the bridge where you can see those
white vehicles along
with nhp they have been there for over
an hour now
assessing the situation taking pictures
and measurements
of course we will keep an eye out on
this situation and any roadway
closures and openings going through as
you can see
now things are moving swiftly and the
northbound lane from the hualapai
overpass
is now open as of now as you can see the
cars are through
and making their way towards deer
springs so that is a good news but of
course we'll keep you updated
and give you the latest coming up at six
o'clock reporting live madison kimbrough
8 news now